بيان حول اعتداءات الميليشيات الايرانيه
على قبور الخلفاء المسلمين في
سوريا الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه
والسلام على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
وبعد فان اعتداءات ايران وميليشياتها
الطائفيه الشيعيه على المدن
السوريه خصوصا مدينه دمشق عاصمه الدوله
الامويه قد بلغت حدا خطيرا واضحت شرا
مستطيرا من خلال مظاهر الاعتداء على تاريخ
دمشق الاسلامي واهانه قبور الخلفاء
المسلمين وتوجيه اللعنات
لاصحابها وان المجلس الاسلامي اذ يدين هذه
الممارسات الطائفيه الاجراميه البشعه
الدنيئه باشد العبارات يبين ما يلي
اولا ان هذا العدوان الاجرامي الذي يقع
على دمشق وغيرها من حواضر العالم الاسلامي
اليوم سيصيب كثيرا من المدن العربيه
والاسلاميه ان لم تبادر تلك
الدول للتصدي للخطر الايراني الطائفي
التوسعي ثانيا ان هذه الممارسات الطائفيه
تتم في مناطق سيطره العصابه الحاكمه
لسوريا تحت سمعها
وبصرها بل بتواطئ مع نظام الولي الفقيه ضد
سوريا وتاريخها وحضارتها
وشعبها وان تلك العصابه شريكه في هذا
الاجرام الذي يمس السوريين والعرب
والمسلمين
جميعا ثالثا
يدعو المجلس الاسلامي الى جعل يوم الجمعه
القادم يوم هبه لشعوب العالمين العربي
والاسلامي ضد الاجرام الايراني هبه تقوم
بها الشعوب في ساحاتها والخطباء في
مساجدهم والاعلامي من مواقعهم يدينون
الاجرام الطائفي الهمجي الايراني ويفضحون
دور العصابه الطائفيه الحاكمه لسوريا في
العدوان الحضاره والتاريخ واستمرارها في
جرائم القتل والتهجير والتغيير
الديموغرافي